[Musique]
la société française va mal
naturellement parce qu'à la pandémie
naturellement parce qu'à la crise
économique mais elle va mal aussi parce
qu'elle est profondément fracturé parce
qu'elles se demandent si encore
aujourd'hui le pacte républicain l'ordre
républicain et le destin collectif de la
nation france ont encore un sens est-ce
que face aux coups de boutoir certes de
la délinquance de plus en plus violente
mais aussi de toute cette contestation
de ce qu'est la france de ce qu'est
l'autorité de l'état partout ces groupes
black blocks racialiste indigéniste
ultra communautariste est-ce qu'il ya
encore un destin commun pour ce pays
monsieur le premier ministre
est ce que en quelques mots devant la
représentation nationale
vous nous dire ce qu'est votre
conception de l'autorité de l'état et de
l'ordre républicain
pour vous répondre la parole etc table
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sueur sénateur karoutchi la
société française va mal vous l'avez dit
est à bien des égards
je crois que je suis d'accord avec vous
non pas que tout irait mal gardons tout
ça n'est pas du tout le sens de votre
question vous garde on doute de dire ou
de penser que tout irait mal en france
ce n'est pas le cas nous avons des
atouts extraordinaires vous les savez et
notons ne tombons pas dans ce travers
français au pessimisme et à l'auto
dénigrement mais soyons lucides comme
vous l'êtes et disons qu'à côté de ces
atouts à côté de ses chances remarquable
que nous avons en france
nous connaissons des difficultés
sérieuses des difficultés économiques
des difficultés sociales
et peut-être même aussi je ne dirais pas
des difficultés morales car le terme
aurait pu avoir un sens il y a longtemps
il ya aujourd'hui un sens qui ne
correspond plus à la réalité
enfin en tout cas au sens que nous lui
donnons mais des difficultés alors
disons les politiques
qu'est ce qu'une nation se référant vous
serez faire un dock ce ce plébiscite
quotidien
cette volonté quotidienne de s'inscrire
dans une longue histoire qui nous
dépassent très largement dont la
complexité nous dépassent très largement
et de vivre ensemble et de construire
quelque chose ensemble une nation ce
n'est pas simplement regarder le passé
et le prendre tel qu'il est c'est
construire à partir de se passer c'est
imaginer l'endroit où nous voulons
aboutir en tant que peuple et bien de ce
point de vue là de ce point de vue là
nous avons manifestement une difficulté
à nous projeter
certains remettent en cause
explicitement les fondements du pacte
républicain
d'autres à mon sens de façon plus
insidieuse et probablement plus
dangereuse remettent en cause ses
fondements
sans le dire et lorsque on revient sur
l'idée de liberté
lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
d'égalité en droits
lorsque l'on revient sur le principes de
l'état de droit de l'autorité de l'état
lorsqu'on revient sur le respect qui est
dû à chaque citoyen lorsqu'on leur
revient lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
même de civisme
si notre régime s'appelle la république
c'est parce qu'elle a eu des
prédécesseurs et une des vertus
cardinales de la république à rome
c'était le civisme c'est à dire non pas
l'exemplarité de tel ou tel mais bien
l'idée que chacun chacun quelles que
soient ses responsabilités qu'il soit
élu ou non et dieu sait qu'on aimait les
élections aussi sommes dépositaires
d'une part celle de ce qu'est le bien
commun et bien ce civisme
on le voit comme progressivement dissous
le respect de l'état pour le voit tous
les jours
remis en cause non pas parce que l'état
serait irréprochable
c'est pas parce que l'état soit
irréprochable qu'il faut le respecter sa
voix parce qu'il saurait mieux que les
autres
ça se saurait c'est parce qu'il est
l'émanation de notre nation et parce
qu'il est là pour faire respecter un
certain nombre de règles qui sont
essentiels à l'intérêt commun l'autorité
de l'état
c'est la capacité monsieur le sénateur à
faire respecter la loi c'est la loi qui
doit prévaloir dans un état de droit
c'est la loi qui doit prévaloir dans la
république la loi et on voit bien que la
force parfois la met en cause on voit
bien que telle ou telle bande que tel ou
tel groupe parfois que tel ou tel
individu veut la faire céder veut la
brise et de la remettre en cause ce
n'est pas un combat récent vous savez
bien monsieur le sénateur c'est un
combat éternel mais c'est un combat qui
aujourd'hui dans notre pays se pose avec
peut-être encore plus d'acuité qu'il ne
s'est posé dans les années qui précèdent
et c'est un fait et bien face à cela il
faut je le crois essayer non pas de
faire taire les débats politiques
ils sont indispensables et jamais il ne
faut les faire taire mais essayez
derrière les débats politiques de
dessiner cet esprit de concorde sur
l'essentiel pas surtout sur l'essentiel
sur les valeurs de la république
il faut soutenir ceux qui font le combat
de la république ministre de l'intérieur
a mille fois raison de soutenir les
forces de l'ordre elles sont au coeur de
ce combat pour la république mais elles
ne sont pas les seuls elles ne sont pas
les seuls la république est née aussi
avec les professeurs la république est
née aussi avec les administrateurs ce
qu'ils construisaient ceux qui
organisaient avec ses représentants de
la force publique
nous leur devons le respect tous et
parfois parce que nous avons le droit de
les critiquer
nous allons impôts de là et nous les
dénigrent ont parfois nous leur donc
nous ne leur donnons pas toujours les
moyens de mettre en oeuvre leur mission
la question vous poser très large
monsieur le sénateur et je sais que vous
et moi nous pourrions disserter des
heures sur ce sujet mais pour moi la
république
ce sont des principes simples c'est
l'état de droit c'est le respect de
l'état c'est l'autorité de l'état et
c'est au delà de tout ça peut être
encore plus le civisme qui fait que être
un citoyen ce n'est pas simplement être
un homme qui a des droits
c'est être un homme ou une femme qui a
des droits et des devoirs
je me suis toujours à titre personnel
monsieur le sénateur étonné de ce qui à
l'époque où le service militaire était
obligatoire vous faisait des leçons
longue comme le bras sur la république
et qui parfois avait eu la faiblesse de
trouver la solution d'échapper au
service militaire
elle nous connaissons tous là c'est le
contraire du 6 et 7 parfois des
tentations qui sont très individuelle
est très personnel voilà ce que je vais
vous dire monsieur le sénateur monsieur
karoutchi chez le premier ministre
la république c'est la liberté c'est
l'égalité c'est la fraternité c'est la
laïcité mais l'état c'est aussi le
garant de l'unité de la nation
et lorsque la société de plus en plus
violente est de plus en plus fracturées
alors il faut s'appuyer pleinement sur
ceux qui défendent la république
on ne peut pas au nom de la liberté
accepter n'importe quel type de
contestation de critiques ou de violence
et le rôle de la police de la république
le rôle de la gendarmerie à l'intérieur
du pays sont essentiels pour soutenir
cette république pour garantir
l'autorité de l'état pour être les
représentants de ce que l'avenir doit
réserver à l'ensemble des français
de la même manière que c'est le rôle de
nos forces armées à l'extérieur la seule
chose monsieur le premier ministre que
l'ensemble des français vous demande
oui nous devons respecter
les forces de l'ordre oui nous devons
respecter les forces de sécurité en
france et ailleurs mais nous devons
aussi tous nous dire que les critiques
violentes ne peuvent pas être acceptées
que la police comme la gendarmerie sont
des corps par définition au service de
la république il peut y avoir des fautes
personnelles
il doit y avoir des sanctions mais il
doit y avoir toujours toujours le
respect de ceux qui défendent la
république
merci la parole est à notre collègue
anne catherine loisier pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur et
revient donc sur les terribles
événements qui ont secoué les quartiers
de dijon et de chenaux ces derniers
jours je voudrais d'abord souligner la
présence de monsieur le secrétaire
d'état hier à dijon une présence
essentielle après quatre jours de
violences urbaines
une présence attendue par une population
sidéré face à des rixes des rixes et des
milices qui elle a subi pendant
plusieurs jours avec le sentiment
parfois d'être livrée à elle-même une
présence attendue bien sûr par les
forces de l'ordre et par les services
préfectoraux qui ont avec les moyens
disponibles avec beaucoup de sang-froid
contenu une situation sans précédent
donc vous avez annoncée des effectifs
supplémentaires en matière de maintien
de l'ordre
vous avez réaffirmé la détermination de
l'état à poursuivre les auteurs des
faits allait sanctionner cela devait
être fait mais pour autant monsieur le
ministre nous savons c'est fait
aujourd'hui ne sont malheureusement pas
isolé et plusieurs villes en france
connaissent des débordements des
représailles
organisé par des communautés rivales
parce que monsieur le secrétaire d'état
a appelé les voyous de plus en plus
lourdement armés et qui se font justice
eux mêmes ça a été dit lorsque l'état de
droit et la république sont menacés dans
leur fondement nous devons faire bloc
nous devons bien sûr soutenir nos forces
de l'ordre et nous devons aussi adapter
nos actions et nos moyens
comment donc monsieur le ministre un
rassemblement de près de 200 individus
tchétchène russe visiblement autres
venant de france est semble-t-il
d'ailleurs au delà nos frontières
mobilisent
via les réseaux sociaux armés et
organisés quasiment militairement n'ont
pas n'ont ils pas été anticipée par les
services de renseignement pourquoi at il
fallu attendre trois jours avant que des
renforts soient effectivement affectés
et enfin plus globalement phase aller au
développement de telles violences et aux
besoins de sécurité de nos populations
comment pensez-vous faire évoluer
l'organisation et les moyens des forces
de l'ordre
merci pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur sur glee c'est
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice à travers
votre témoignage vous rebondissez une
nouvelle fois sur ce sujet majeur le
fait que jamais nos forces de sécurité
routière ne rechigne quand elles sont
sollicitées et vous avez raison
au moment où ce groupe d'individus est
apparu dans la ville de dijon
il n'y avait pas eu d'anticipation en
matière de renseignement et pourtant les
forces de sécurité intérieure qui
n'était pas numériquement en capacité de
faire face qui n'étaient pas préparés
ont répondu présent et elles n'ont cessé
de répondre présent ensuite le préfet a
eu connaissance de cela j'ai changé avec
le maire de dijon
j'ai échangé avec le préfet je lui ai
demandé de piloter personnellement la
situation pour faire en sorte qu' il n'y
ait pas ces échauffourées
je dirais bande contre bond et encore je
ne sais pas si on peut qualifier comme
ça cette horde de sauvages totalement
insupportable vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
il n'est pas question qu'il y ait un
mètre carré dans notre pays où la
république recule y compris face à ces
violences extrêmes et nous devons faire
en sorte que signé nulle part d' état de
non droit et que l'état soit toujours
présent pour juguler juguler ces dérives
totalement insupportable totalement
inacceptable et le phénomène de violence
qu'a connu dijon pendant quatre jours
même si la nuit dernière les choses
étaient apaisées et malgré cela j'ai
demandé au préfet que près de 200 hommes
femmes la gendarmerie de la police 13
présente j'ai demandé que la berri et
que le raid reste présent aussi dans les
jours qui viennent et ils reviendront en
tant que de besoin
tout comme j'ai demandé aussi à nos
services de police de veillée sous
l'autorité du ministère de la justice à
ce que l'identification des auteurs de
ces exactions commises dès samedi
se poursuivent et qui est des recherches
individuelles pour qu'ils ne soient pas
laissés libres l'idée qu'il serait
impunis ils ne seront pas impunis
madame la sénatrice vous l'avez dit nos
forces de sécurité intérieure ont
répondu elles ont rendu avec
l'engagement elles ont répondu avec le
courage et elle mérite pour cela d'être
salué je sais l'émotion je la partage ce
qui s'est passé est inacceptable
il est insupportable et sachez que où
que ce soit en france nous ferons
reculer ces pratiques de voyous
les premières victimes de votre
politique sont les salariés peu diplômés
et les jeunes déjà durement touchée par
les causes et les conséquences du
confinement
pourquoi vous obstinez vous dans ses
choix recueilli qui n'ont pas donné de
résultats probants
sauf pour les actionnaires quand
allez-vous faire le choix d'une économie
orientée vers l'emploi au service d'une
autre production qui protège et qui
donne du travail au plus grand nombre
allez vous enfin partager le travail
pour permettre l'épanouissement de
chacun et ne pas contraindre toujours
plus ceux qui ont un emploi en
précarisant les autres cette voie
nouvelle vous devez l'explorer et ne pas
rester bloqués sur les vieux dogmes
libéraux pour vous répondre la parole
est à mme la ministre du travail madame
pénicaud monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
la sénatrice michel gréaume le président
effectivement appelé la collectivité
nationale à travailler davantage
quel est le sujet en france
je pense que nous serons d'accord à peu
près tous pour dire que pourra avoir un
au système de solidarité comme nous le
voulons tous en france il faut produire
la richesse nationale
c'est la richesse nationale qui produit
aussi la capacité est un grand pays être
compétitif mais aussi assurer un haut
niveau de protection de solidarité
nationale ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
refusant de faire natio des minorités
hystériser veulent réécrire l'histoire
de france on m'accuse la statue du
général de gaulle on appelle à
déboulonner louis xiv napoléon jules
ferry au crash sur les figures qui ont
bâti notre histoire d tentation
obscurantiste
guette notre société certes dimanche le
chef de l'état a condamné une ré culture
haineuse ou fausses on ne déboulonnera
pas de statut at il martelé
ces propos et faste il pour autant ceux
du candidat qu'il fût déclarant que la
colonisation était un crime contre
l'humanité une vraie barbarie pour
laquelle il devait présenter ses excuses
sur le buste de jean baptiste colbert
grand commis d'état et qui fait notre
pays une puissance navale sous des
auspices de jules ferry qui préside à
notre institution et fonda notre école
républicaine
pouvez-vous nous assurer que les travaux
historiques et scientifiques qui replace
toujours l'action des femmes et des
hommes dans leur époque se re protéger
êtes vous prêt à ne jamais laisser
réécrire l'histoire à ne jamais laisser
les émotions du moment faire le tri
entre zones d'ombré et passage
étincelant pouvez-vous nous assurer que
l'on continuera à écrire et enseigner
l'histoire de france non sous la
dictature d'une pensée militante
largement communautariste mais avec
l'esprit civique tt et la recherche de
l'universalisme qui caractérise l
héritage des lumières pour vous répondre
la parole qu'à monsieur le premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
je suis président mesdames et messieurs
comme le disait sénateurs imminent qui a
siégé près de 18 ans dans cette
assemblée
la révolution est un bloc l'histoire de
france est un bloc la révolution pour
aller dans le sens du président
retailleau est un bloc et dans la
révolution nous prenons condorcet et
saint-just danton et robespierre valmy
et la vendée le général dumas el général
bonaparte
nous prenons tout parce que parce que
parce qu'en fait en vérité monsieur le
sénateur ne vont pas le choix c'est
notre histoire avec des choses glorieuse
avec des choses plus compliquées et même
avec des choses qui ne sont en rien
glorieuses et qui sont franchement
sombre peut-on me désigner une période
de l'histoire un homme ou une femme qui
ayant fait quelque chose
serais tu de toute évidence et dans tous
les aspects lumineux et n'aurait pas sa
part d'ombré
sérieusement
m
ah ah
ce sens qu'au sénat on me dit il y à
gérard larcher je crains monsieur le
président que même vous plus
sérieusement avant moi il ya eu l'abbé
grégoire ici monsieur le président
monsieur le président même lui même les
non notre histoire et et glorieuse et
est compliquée et vouloir procéder à une
forme d'épuration mémorielle me paraît
aussi dangereux d'une certaine façon que
vouloir procéder à d'autres types
d'épuration nous devons regarder notre
histoire en face évidemment et au fond
ce c'est ce que nous faisons c'est pas
toujours facile d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le seul
point sur lequel je me distingue un tout
petit peu de votre question monsieur le
sénateur vous dites est ce que est ce
que vous allez empêcher qu'on réécrivent
l'histoire mais la vérité dans le
processus scientifique qu'est l'histoire
c'est que l'histoire se récrie en
permanence la vision que l'on a
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
grands hommes ou de grande époque où de
grands événements et peut-être un peu
différente c'est vrai de celle qui
prévalait il ya trente ans où il ya 200
ans bien sûr bien sûr on ne lit plus
aujourd'hui le règne de françois 1er
comme on le lisait à l'époque où
quelques années après mais justement
nous sommes au sénat le haut lieu de la
république et nous travaillons sous les
auspices de saint louis
bah oui parce que c'est l'histoire de la
france je voudrais dire monsieur le
sénateur pour aller dans votre sens que
comme vous sans doute j'ai été
profondément choqué parce que je pense
que ça traduit une profonde
je ne trouve pas le mot mais en tout cas
quelque chose qui ne va pas j'étais pro
photo qu'est profondément choqué qu à
fort de france
on déboulonne les statuts le victor
schoelcher à fort de france qui étaient
de même et peut-être pourrions nous
engager un combat commun sur le sénateur
profondément déçu non pas choqué parce
que on va essayer de rattraper le coup
mais profondément déçu que la république
la quatrième d'abord la cinquième
ensuite ne reconstruisent pas la statue
au général dumas qui a été fondue par
les nazis en 1940 1941 le général dumas
qui dit beaucoup plus de choses sur ce
qu'est l'idéal républicain
le père d'alexandre celui dont
anatole-france disais et je vais dire le
mot parce qu'il montre combien notre
histoire est difficile anatole france
prix nobel de littérature disait le plus
grand des dumas c'est le fils de la
négresse intel france aujourd'hui le
monde est impossible à juste titre mais
dans la bouche d'anatole france c'est
plus bel hommage républicain qu'on
puisse faire alors peut-être monsieur le
sénateur si vous le voulez nous
pourrions vous et moi
militer pour la reconstruction de la
statue du général dumas cheveux
brillants
ce premier liste je vous ai demandé de
protéger les travaux des historiens et
leur capacité d'écrire l'histoire avec
l'esprit critique qui nous
caractéristiques qui nous caractérise
mcb leur rappeler qu'entre tous les
péchés regard d'une science du temps le
plus impardonnable était dans un
communisme on sait bien lui aujourd'hui
est utilisé par des minorités prête à de
réels autodafé au delà de ce cousin
disent surpris ministre je vous exhorte
à que l'érection de gars de l'exécutif
au-delà de ces contradictions soit la
hauteur des outrages c'est une autre
histoire et aux femmes et aux hommes qui
l'ont bâti monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
monsieur misé intérieur quoi qu'il vous
en coûte l'autorité de l'état est
malmené
malgré la brillante tirade de monsieur
le premier ministre et la leçon
édifiante de roger karoutchi l'autorité
républicaine est malmené par la violence
elle est malmenée par le mépris des
forces de l'ordre mais elle est
également malmené par des comportements
qui substitue la tambouille électorale
au respect des principes démocratiques
ce n'est pas la règle qui doit vous
tenir
c'est à vous de tenir la règle il ya de
démocratie que si les élections se
tiennent à des dates fixes et régulière
alors que les élections régionales sont
prévues en mars 2021
les raisons annoncées d'un report de
plus d'un an laisse perplexe inaugurant
la date d'élections pour convenance
personnelle au mieux pour convenance de
la république en marche au pire selon la
presse le président de la république
descendant du grenier à la cave se
serait livré à une tractations de
marchands de tapis avec les présidents
de région je cite je vous aide
financièrement si vous m'aidez à
reporter les régionales après la
présidentielle car j'ai des opposants
politiques parmi vous aurait il déclaré
ajoutant je ne vais pas donner de
l'argent à mes adversaires
on apprend que le président de la
république à des adversaires et n'est
donc pas le président de tous les
français considérant que l'argent public
des régions est le sien et que du fait
du prince
il distribue à qui bon lui semble comme
le disait xavier bertrand derrière les
élections il ya le peuple et le peuple
on le respecte alors monsieur le
ministre
allez vous renoncer à cette manoeuvre
grossière allez vous travailler avec
tous tes région élu démocratiquement et
dans la compétence légitime elle
développement économique pour vous
répondre la parole les faux milices de
l'intérieur président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
permettez moi d'avoir une petite pensée
sur ce qu'est être républicain et elle
sera très personnelle ou m'interroger
sur les élections régionales
je sais monsieur le sénateur ce qu'est
être républicain pour préserver
justement la république et faire en
sorte que dans ma région
ce soit un président les républicains
qui soit élu parce que je sais aussi ne
pas me tromper de combat et de la même
façon monsieur le sénateur
ce que je sais c'est qu'il vaut mieux
certainement écouté l'actuel président
de la région provence alpes côte d'azur
monsieur renaud muselier qui a contesté
les fêtes que vous avez évoquées qui a
contesté ces paroles et qui les a
démenties alors je nous invite à rester
sur l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est quoi
monsieur le sénateur ça ne pas ce qui a
été rapporté par la presse
l'essentiel c'est votre conclusion et je
la rejoins parfaitement celle justement
de cette compétence économique majeur
qu'exercent les collectivités locales et
les régions en particulier et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut réécouter
le président de la république et non pas
lui prêter quelques propos dimanche il a
dit qu'il y avait deux priorités
la première c'est celle de la relance
économique et social de notre pays nous
en avons parlé vous êtes engagés sur ces
sujets je le sais il évoquer un deuxième
chantier majeur celui de nouveau partage
territorial des compétences et des
pouvoirs celui de savoir s'appuyer sur
les collectivités locales qui font
l'action notamment économiques
et comme vous je pense aux et vos
conseils régionaux il a évoqué cela avec
deux présidents de région dont le
président de l'association des régions
de france et cela la réalité et si nous
franchissons cette étape une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation
il n'est pas illégitime de discuter avec
les
président de région de la meilleure
façon de les accompagner dans
l'opérationnalité concrètes dollar
action pour défendre l'économie dans nos
territoires et relancer l'emploi partout
c'est nécessaire et en même temps de
discuter avec elle s'il ya une réforme
en profondeur de quel est le bon moment
pour la mettre en place un seul objectif
monsieur le sénateur ne pas empêcher
l'action de la relance économique par
des élections il est légitime que ces
discussions puissent avoir lieu avec les
présidents élus ou en fonction dans nos
régions c'est cela la réalité ne
qualifiait pas cela de tambouille
il s'agit au contraire d'un dialogue
démocratique rf aux concurrents il est
important que nous nous posions tous
ensemble sans arrière pensée sur la
table je vous remercie monsieur de chair
pour quelques secondes
en cette veille du 18 juin je vous
invite à ne pas capituler sur la
démocratie
et je vous rappelle à ce triptyque
historique pour gouverner la france
l'honneur le bon sens l'intérêt
supérieur de la patrie c'est vrai n'est
pas le général qui veut de gaulle qui
veut monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé
l'hôpital public est en crise les
soignants souffre vous avez engagé le
ségur de la santé pour répondre à ces
difficultés le président de la
république a promis un système du souple
plus simple plus en proximité en
revalorisant le collectif le sens de
l'équipe et l'initiative des
professionnels
l'ouverture de ce chantier s'imposait
c'était une excellente nouvelle trois
semaines après son lancement il nous en
nous aspire pourtant quelques
inquiétudes majeures
le gouvernement est absent de la table
des négociations les syndicats
d'infirmiers n'y étais même pas convié
le doute parcours de très nombreuses
organisations syndicales toutes
dénoncent des sujets escamoté et
craignent que les arbitrages soient déjà
réalisés elles redoutent un simulacre de
concertation pour calmer leur colère
grande foutaise selon certains
urgentistes le ségur suscite l'hostilité
de tous les soignants qui manifestaient
partout en france hier monsieur le
ministre la guerre de guerre lasse les
soignants attendent des garanties des
garanties financières bien sûr mais pas
seulement
il faut des garanties quant aux
conditions de travail
il faut des garanties sur la question
des effectifs hospitaliers
il faut des garanties sur la formation
et la recherche médicale qui doivent
être liés aux soins pour préparer nos
soignants aux métiers de demain
il faut des garanties pour refaire de la
france un pays leader en matière de
prévention et de soins
il faut des garanties quant à la place
qu'occuperont les territoires dans la
direction
la direction des soins les chefs de
service les médecine la médecine de
ville
les ars les chu ou encore l'hôpital
privé
si l'on ne rompt pas avec le fléau
bureaucratique la centralisation de la
décision le cloisonnement des structures
et bien l'augmentation des salaires
soulagement soulagera momentanément la
douleur sans soigner le mal profond
alors monsieur le ministre entendez-vous
enfin adopté une méthode réel de
concertation appuyé sur les territoires
et sur les soignants merci pour vous
répondre la parole le tableau dames la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé vous avez la
parole monsieur le sénateur cédric
perrin vous l'avez dit des
manifestations hier ont eu lieu et je
crois que c'est aussi le symbole de ce
qu'attendent de l'ensemble des soignants
et de ce qu'ils ont pu vivre le temps de
la crise et c'est pour ça que le
président de la république et le premier
ministre se sont exprimés se sont
engagés à travailler sur la
revalorisation et surtout organisations
salariales
qu'il s'agisse du secteur hospitalier
hospital in mais aussi du secteur médico
social notamment par le biais d épargne
parce que c'est un ensemble et c'est
face à saintes ensemble face aux crises
depuis plusieurs années notre système
hospitalier de ce qu'ont vécu et si
notre système de santé a tenu face au co
vie 19 c'est aussi parce que les
soignants était bien l'un était bien
présent avec des coopérations qui était
sans précédent quand on parle hôpital
public hôpital privé quand on parle
médecine de ville l'hôpital quand on
parle de lever des lourdeurs qui ont pu
se faire grâce à de linge de lit du
dialogue et qui jusqu'à présent n'avait
pas lieu et c'est bien dans un seul
objectif c'est bien de soigner et de
sauver nos nos concitoyens et c'est dans
ce cadre là que segura été lancé par le
premier ministre le ministre de la santé
pour pouvoir concertée et cette carte
sans concertation on veut rapide parce
que la réponse doit être apportée
rapidement c'est une nécessité c'est une
demande
des soignants ce nécessité de l'ensemble
du système de santé c'est pour ça que
les consultations sont en cours elles
sont rapides j'ai dit avec les premières
propositions mi juillet près de 300
acteurs autour de la table qui vont des
médecins qu'ils aillent des infirmiers
l'ensemble des participants sont
présents 300 acteurs autour de la table
avec des groupes de travail thématiques
quatre piliers thématiques
la réalisation est un temps spécifique
aux six décès au territoire sur lequel
l'organisation sont en cours sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour que les
bonnes pratiques de la gestion de la
crise du coc vide pis pro montée puisse
nous apporter des solutions et c'est
l'objectif du ségur et les conclusions
seront apportés mi juillet je vous
remercie
[Musique]